what's up guys today we're taking a look
at the Intel i7 8700 k + CI performs
let's jump right in so in the front it
has a core i7 logo and on the side
there's some barcodes on the back you
can see the CPU to the little window and
there's some technical information same
on the bottom there's some technical
information there as well there's a
little table here that you're supposed
to open and it says factory sealed and
there's some more technical information
on the side right here and top which is
plate so simply open the factory seal
thing and comes right open inside
there's a little tab right here you pull
that little CPU straight out with a
little pamphlet little manual here and
has the sticker on the back if you guys
like that so after that there's little
tabs on both sides you pull out and come
straight over now you can take the CPU
out and here there's been a little tab
on this side right here
and CPU coming straight out this is
Intel here's the Intel i7 8700 K okay
guys I hope you guys enjoyed that really
quick unboxing of the Intel i7 8700 K
I've done an in detail review on the CPU
and done in detail overclocking and seen
how it performs so if you guys want to
see that make sure to click the link in
description below that's all for now if
you guys liked this video make sure to
give it a like if you loved it and wanna
see more videos just like this make sure
to subscribe and turn on the biota
fication cuz that's all for now guys bye
[Music]